here we are right good evening everyone
and uh
welcome to this meeting with the
executive if i go through a few
housekeeping issues i will now read out
the emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building
via the rear doors to the hall turn
right
go through the two sets of double doors
to the car park which is the assembly
point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please
switch off mobile phones and put them to
silent or put them to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use
during the meeting when i invite you to
speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other
and use the hand gel and antibacterial
wipes on the tables if you do touch the
microphones
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
then against
recommendations numbers not voting will
be noted
by officers all right that's a bit of a
different introduction to the zoom
meeting isn't it so that livened it up a
bit
good right agenda item
number one apologies for absence and
we've received
no apologies moving on to
item number two non-members attending
councillor eileen gadsden welcome and
indeed welcome to our two members of the
public also attending
moving to the minutes of
the 14th of april 2021
members are the minutes look in that
direction members are the minutes
agreed agreed
item number four to receive declarations
of pinterest
members are there any declarations of
interest
i'm not seeing any
item number five questions on notice
from councillors
there are none
matters referred to the executive
reports from other committees
there are none so to the main event of
the evening which is
agenda item number seven provisional
financial out turn
the portfolio holder for financial
services council simon smith will
present the report council smith
thank you chairman um before i get
started i'd
just like to take the opportunity to
thank
naomi and her team for all the work
that has gone into this it's condensed
into a
a small report but it should know me by
no means uh
take away from the sheer quantity of
work that goes into
preparing our financial figures
i've got a number of uh points that i
i'll talk you through
the original general fund revenue budget
was 9.8 million
the provisional outrun was 10.3 million
which is unfavorable variance of 0.5
million
in addition to the original base budget
one million pound of
drawdowns from reserves was approved for
specific purposes
during the year and these are detailed
in appendix 2.
it's requested to carry forward 1.4
million of budget
relating to specific projects grant
funded expenditure
on one-off items including 0.5 million
of sales fees and charges
compensation grant income into 2122
as detailed in appendices 4a and 4b
once these items are accounted for the
overall overspend
rises to 0.9 million the
this underlying overspend reflects the
impact of cobit 19 on service budget
areas
to help mitigate these these pressures
the government provided the council with
a coveted 19
general grant allocation of 1.1 million
application of this grant reduces the
net position
to 8.2 million underspend which is a
small increase of sixty thousand pounds
compared to the position reported to the
executive
in quarter three back in february
as well as the general kobit nineteen
grand the government has also provided
several of the specific
covid19 grand allegations which are
reported separately
the details of these can be found in the
table at appendix
4c the capital programme
totaling 2.9 million
was approved at full council in february
2020.
the executive agreed to reprofile this
in quarter one
giving a revised capital budget of 1.9
million
the provisional outrun capital outrun
position
is 1.2 million as set out in appendix 5.
this includes 0.5 million of slippage on
projects
mainly due to cobit 19 delaying
completion of works
this is requested to be carried forward
into 21-22
the council holds sufficient reserves
and balances to support the long-term
longer-term financial stability of the
council
although it should be noted that the
majority of these reserves
are earmarked for specific purposes and
will not be available
unless decisions are taken to reconsider
the council's strategic priorities
and associate other associated funding
commitments
the reserve's position is detailed at
appendix
3. to summarise the report shows that
despite the adverse impacts of cobit 19
on the council's budgets
additional grant funding combined with
savings on salaries
and other budgets has meant that the
council has been able to contain its
pressures
in the short term and deliver against
its corporate priorities
while maintaining its planned
contributions to reserves
for projects such as the connect program
program
however the covid 19 losses and cost
pressures experienced in 2021
are continuing into twenty one twenty
two
and may extend into the medium term
the government's income compensation
scheme will
continue for the first quarter of 21 22
and some additional grant support has
been made available
for this financial year however the
council
is likely to have to take difficult
decisions
to ensure its financial sustainability
in the median term
unless additional ongoing resources are
planned
are agreed for local authorities as part
of the
comprehensive spending review which is
planned in 2021
chairman you can't say by any means
that last year was a good year last year
was a terrible year
in all sorts of ways but in terms of the
way in which we've
managed our budget i do believe we have
we have performed as well as we possibly
could given all the circumstances
and so therefore i ask the executive to
recommend
to approve the recommendations to set
out on the 10 points
in section 1 of the report thank you
thank you councillor smith
are there any questions at this stage
for either councillor smith
or for him to delegate and ask naomi
lucas to
help us out any questions members
council award thank you chairman it's
just an observation
that at how well we have done in
consideration
of the shocking period that we've had
it is a great credit i think to
everybody
who works and is part of locksmith
district council
that we've actually got ourselves
through what could have been
an awful financial mess
that we've come out this way it's it's
amazing to be quite honest and
i have to say i have to be very proud to
be a member of this executive in this
council
that has worked so well to actually
achieve and
give credit to the portfolio holder and
naomi and her staff
in what's going on but not only that to
all the ladies
and the acting manager director because
you know we've had to
ban some enormous costs and we've got
through it
and i have to applaud them thank you
counselor
thank you very much indeed any other
comments from members
no i wish to uh make a few points before
the girl's recommendations and council
award
uh you and i didn't speak before this
meeting but you could have stolen
my speech but nevertheless so i'm
actually going to say
much for saying that under the
stewardship of portfolio holder
simon smith we have been fortunate to be
able to steer a ship
politically in an extremely sound
way and i like you i'm extremely proud
to be
the leader of this council at this time
it will be a very difficult time
but i also want to pay tribute to naomi
lucas who steers the financial ship
and is the founder of all knowledge to
whom we refer on occasions and
and frankly she knows from other
meetings that i've had with her
i constantly repeat my appreciation to
her although i know
the portfolio holder officially does
that but actually when you read this
report it is a tribute to all
officers senior officers in particular
but actually all officers
for the way that they manage their
directorates and
the tough times that we have and i'm
actually going to read
the first paragraph of this report
because i think
it's appropriate to place that on record
and
actually read 2.1 the financial impact
of kobit 19 has been an evolving picture
throughout 2021
and this uncertainty will continue into
2021
to 2022. managing the 2020-21 budget has
been
significantly more challenging than
usual due to the ongoing impacts of
covid19 on the council's finances
staff residents and the local economy
the council has played a significant
role in responding to the pandemic
supporting businesses and the most
vulnerable in our communities
as well as continuing to provide
essential services to all residents
furthermore what we were able to do in
this year's budget
was continue to invest in our community
investing in our car parks
investing in community safety investing
in our town centres in terms of
making them fit for the return to life
in normality so it is a huge tribute
to officers and to members
particularly the executive for the way
they steer their various portfolios
in conjunction with senior officers so i
do actually want to pay my tribute
in that way before i turn to the
recommendations any further comments
no okay i'm going to take these in in
groups of threes and fours as there's 10
uh recommendations so if you turn to
paragraphs 1.1 to 1.10
the first recommendation is to note the
provisional out turn position
against the 2021 revenue budget as
contained in paragraphs
2.1 to 2.9 is that noted members
noted
1.2 to note that the council's 2020
2020 to 21 statement of accounts are
still being prepared
and will be subject to audit by the
external auditors
student young it is therefore possible
that changes will be made to the
financial out turn
which should could alter the position
presented within this report is that
noted members
now it is and 1.3 is to approve the
transfer
to the business rate smoothing reserves
of 3071 pound
three point oh here we go three million
seventy one thousand and one hundred and
fifty nine
pounds set out in paragraph 2.9
the non-service specific expenditure
approved
yes could i have a show of hands please
and that is clearly unanimous
i must look to see where the commas are
in the long numbers must not so
i get the millions right
right moving on to um
1.4 to note the detailed breakdown of
each portfolio's
provisional out turn position at
appendix one
is that noted members
to note the detailed breakdown of
in-year reserve
movements at appendix 2 is that noted
to note the projected earmarked reserves
closing balance
at the 31st of march 2021
as set out in appendix 3 which includes
the impact
of items 1.7 to 1.8
below is that noted members
[Music]
to approve 1 million 422
909 pounds of revenue carried
carry forwards comprised of one million
one hundred and eighty four thousand one
hundred and twenty
pounds of grant budgets and
two hundred and thirty eight thousand
seven hundred and ninety pounds of
general budgets
as set out in appendix 4a and 4b
and i guess on 1.7 we have to have a
show of hands so
can i have a show of hands to approve it
and that again is unanimous
moving on to 1.8 to note the code
19 grants position detailed at appendix
4c
including ring fenced amounts to be
rolled forward
into 2021 to 2022
is that noted members noted
1.9 to note the provisional out turn
position
against the 2020 21 capital budget
as contained in paragraphs 2.12
and 213 and detailed in appendix 5.
is that noted members noted
thank you and finally 1.10
to approve 496
183 pounds of capital project
carry forwards for those schemes deemed
outstanding
at the end of 2020 to 21
into 2021 22
for completion as detailed in appendix 6
and again can i have a show of hands
please to approve that
unanimous
so members at um
7 47 p.m that actually concludes
the business of the evening so thank you
very much indeed for
to everyone for attending thank you